ouais
ça pourrait être joli nom ce dilemme
soit sa tête mais on va être disqualifié
et c'est ça qui me dérange pas ça
continue ce gros sous
qu'est-ce que ça s'appelle croque tout
faux pas complètement perdu
bah quoi ça change c'est bien d'essayer
de nouveaux trucs plus moi j'ai pas
besoin de goûter pour savoir que c'est
dégueulasse ça quant aux flux
davos lors qu'ils fassent ton original
de nuit qu'est ce que tu vas glander à
paris m'a pesé j'en avais envie
vous avez un itinéraire qui nous fait
passer devant des jolis monuments chez
super tendres si vous voulez la sur la
gauche c'est le siège social de rap
assistance à super
[Musique]
bonjour c'est quoi un accent je suis ton
noir
ça veut dire qu'on aille se balader
ensemble je sais même pas comment vous
appelez à brigitte elle va revenir vous
inquiétez pas c'est comment tu sais ça
parce que je le sais voilà
je suis monté à paris
[Applaudissements]
je les ai vus avec un homme
elle vous aime votre femme
qu'est ce qu'ils m'ont dit jim je croque
une fois une petite dépression
ça c'est depuis qu'on l'a séparé de bora
bora de plus il a cru qu'elle était
partie s'est mis à faire n'importe quoi
mais allez revis tout est rentré dans
l'aude c'est sûr ça
[Musique]